[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tim mcmahon has done a wonderful job
whenever i see that he has posted
something on the mothership
i uh usually stop to read that and i saw
the latest article and granted
tim doesn't come up with a headline but
the headline caught my attention james
harden and the rockets are
at a breaking point and tim mcmahon
joins us now uh
what do you mean by that tim they're at
a breaking point
well look obviously james horton wants
out
the rockets at some point will uh
accommodate that
at a point when they deem appropriate
when they feel like there's
fair value on the table but really what
the rockets are right now is that a
cultural reckoning for eight years the
rockets
business philosophy when it came to
basketball was kiss
james harden's ass and let's keep him as
happy as possible
and that has spanned two owners uh
really daryl moore was the ringleader he
worked his butt off to get a star to get
a superstar he was right on james harden
when a lot of people thought he was
taking a huge risk on this guy who was a
sixth man in okc
and they did whatever they possibly
could to keep them happy and and
from you know they're really these this
is not necessarily an
unusual philosophy it's not unusual for
a superstar to be able to determine
what the travel schedule is to be able
to determine what the prac schedule is
now harden would determine that based on
what the club scene was in
a certain city whether they were going
to stay over or not or you know
try to schedule hey they off let me get
to vegas
that sort of thing but and then the
power and uh in the personnel moves you
know determining
who's coaching determining whose
co-stars is
and then honestly i think all this stuff
there's still not a necessarily
consensus people who are with rockets
people who
are still with the rockets whether it
was the right approach because look
they got eight years of superstar
performance you know they got
a pretty mvp candidate type performance
they didn't get to the top of the
mountain
but they were that handful of teams have
had a chance to contend
but it's crashing down on them now and
really it's the chris paul in a package
of picks
for one year of rust that everybody
wants out
that is the the power flex by james
harden
that is just crippling the rockets
franchise at this point but i don't
understand it he built it and now he
wants to escape it
it's like hey i built this house but i
don't like it i got to get out
it's on fire here he's the one that
built this thing
and then i don't know where this came
from and maybe you can help me that
he had a problem with ownership and
their politics
uh that that was a reason that he wanted
him
i know that's been out there i'll just
say nothing in my reporting has
suggested okay that's been an issue so i
i can't really speak on the political
thing because again
i i'm not i don't have that reporting i
i don't know if there's any
uh any truth to that um i'll tell you
this though if i build a house
and that thing starts burning i'm
getting the hell out
but he's not the fire though tim well
hey he's the arsonist
and i do not i do not disagree with you
um
i i think you are absolutely right i
think if we want to look at this thing
i think there's a lot of blame that you
can pass around i do think james
harden's taking a big slice of that and
you know insert your punchline on uh on
his waistline at this point
um but this is the reality of the
situation and
you know what at some point he will get
his wish to be traded
he will not get to dictate the terms of
that trade he could dictate the terms of
chris paul
and a bundle of picks for russell
westbrook because he could say hey
you either get russ or i'm going to be a
problem and i'm going to want to get the
hell out of here
he wants to get the hell out now he
can't dictate the terms where he goes to
this point
i do think there will be an offer that
the rockets deem fair
at some point uh before the trade
deadline but it's it's not on the table
right now
and you don't have to trade him to a
contender because his list
oh by the way is is filled with really
good teams
like you know why not say we're gonna
not that
and we've talked about this before the
knicks don't have the assets here but
sacramento or somebody like that that
why am i
why am i giving in i'm enabling one more
time
by saying well okay james we're going to
send you to where you know you want to
go
why would sacramento trade for james
harden knowing he wants
nothing to do with being there knowing
he's going to be unhappy
knowing that in two years getting a hell
out of doctors so that's the thing
it's not that he necessarily gets to
pick his team and he's gone from
brooklyn brooklyn brooklyn to well
philly and maybe these other team you
know but it's not that he gets to pick
the team but it has to make sense for
that team as well because
especially if if the asking price
remains what it is
young franchise cornerstone and a bundle
of picks and or
promising talent on rookie contracts
you're giving up a ton to get them
so you're not going to give up a ton to
get a guy who's
man just unhappy you know and doesn't
want to be there it's going to be
you know it's going to be a miserable
experience then he's going to be gone
but okay handicap this though for me tim
if we look at this
does milwaukee have the assets given
what they want is not a factor in this
milwaukee is not a factor
i mean they gave up their draft picks
they gave up a lot to get drew holliday
well that and giannis and hardin have
taken
several shots but other than that
all right philly if if philly says we'll
give you ben simmons
and whoever tobias harris or something
well it would be what the what the
rockets will want there
is ben simmons and picks okay
could be a pick um and look
pj tucker is probably getting traded at
some point too he would make a lot of
sense if he's traded along with harden
to philly daryl moray obviously knows
both players well
pj tucker is a you know great uh role
player on a
expiring contract you can so you can
expand the deal that way but yeah that
it's ben simmons and then you haggle
over picks you haggle weather titles in
the deal
i still think uh that is the most
likely scenario um i'm not certain that
there is a
consensus within the sixers organization
that they want
to to have anything to do with those
kind of discussions
and then i look at the miami heat and i
i have somebody who works there and i
just said you know give me the validity
of
you know that possibility and and you
know so i guess they're exploring this
and if bam out of bio and tyler hero
would be the two assets that you might
be able to get okay if if i'm houston
you got my attention
because i do have young players i have
an all-star maybe a potential all-star
there
and maybe i i get rid of all this drama
and uh there's a little addition by
subtraction there
but if i'm miami like jimmy butler had a
hard time playing
in philly and seven and minnesota
because of
you know these players who were immature
i mean james harden
can be immature and uh wanted his way i
can't imagine jimmy butler putting up
with the tardiness of
james harden well and you know i i do
think james harden the heat culture
could be an interesting fit and
you know maybe he adapts uh you know
james harden when he gets created i
think there will be an understanding
that his legacy
is on the line um jimmy butler and james
harden do have a relationship
of course so did james and russ much
longer
and chris paul yo yeah it's funny though
uh the rockets thought they were getting
jimmy butler
not this off season last off season had
it lined up they're ready to ship out to
pelham gordon to make the room
uh hardin and butler had been talk and
they were ready and then jimmy goes to
them and went inside literally did not
return texts and phone calls and
and went to miami um but look those
things
players get over those kind of things um
but
miami i would imagine would the first
thing they would say is hell no bam is
not
on the table absolutely not don't even
ask again
but hiro would absolutely intrigue the
rockets duncan robinson would absolutely
intrigue the rockets
they've the heat have several vets on
expiring contracts where you can make
the money work
they're a little bit limited in picks
but there's there's absolutely ways
for uh offer an offer that makes sense
to be
to be put together for miami he's tim
mcmahon he covers the nba for espn
um how much better are the lakers
now than they were a couple of months
ago
well you know obviously we've got to see
how things fit on paper i think they're
significantly better mark assault to me
is a
is a major upgrade over what they had a
center a much different player
but still because of his physicality and
intelligence
a great defense player i think
a little bit of a better fit offensively
just because he can space the floor and
give
a.d some room to work uh and then
schroeder you know schroeder and harold
schruter right now wants to start we'll
see my guess is there's some kind of
smooth transition to get him back coming
off the bench and that schroeder herald
pick and roll coming off the bench is a
ton
of firepower and look if lebron is
healthy
and 80's healthy the lakers are the
favorites whether they upgraded the
supporting cast or not
but they did the most interesting team
people aren't talking about is who
the most interesting team people aren't
talking about
that is a good question i'm trying to
figure out who people
aren't talking about people are talking
about phoenix um
people aren't talking i don't know that
the nuggets even though they went to the
west finals i don't know if the nuggets
are
a franchise that people talk about a
whole lot and obviously jokic is a
perennial nba candidate
uh jamal murray at 23 if if the bubble
was a
was it breaking out for him was a
springboard for him they've got another
star there
michael porter jr is one of the most
fascinating
talents in the league you know we'll see
if he can put it together if he does
you know they potentially have a third
star the other thing is
if they wanted to be aggressive in the
trade market michael porter jr is
absolutely the kind of you know he can
be a centerpiece
to go get a uh to go get a star i mean
look if the nuggets caught the rockets
and they're talking porter junior picks
and you know like gary harris barton
combo to make some salaries work
those conversations could heat up that's
interesting did the clippers improve
i think the clippers i think mantra's
herald
leaving probably needed to happen for
the clippers from a chemistry standpoint
i think serge ibaka
comes in there and maybe fits a little
bit better
you know with the kawhi paul george
combo there's not the
you know old clips versus uh you know
kind of the new regime
there ibaka is i mean as a as a backup
center
or starter really is a is a heck of a
player
i i need to see it from the clippers and
honestly my biggest concern about the
clippers
is paul george and paul george now
and definitely paul george as that uh
extension kicks in
and he ages let's be honest paul george
just
kind of crumbled under the pressure of
being
a superstar on a team expected to
contend
so to me out of out of all the guys who
are all nba caliber players
he might have the most to prove this
season your honest reaction when you saw
that he got that
super that max extension
well does everybody have to get that tim
like couldn't they say you know what
you're not worth the max
paul you're a b maybe a b-plus player
why does everybody have to get the max i
don't understand this
well yeah that's a good question and you
know why does uh
why do superstars have to be able to
determine the practice and travel
schedules and flex their power with
personnel moves it's just
it is a player run league that's just
the way it is
and with the clippers they went all in
on paul george
uh when they pushed all those picks shea
gil just alexander galinari
put that massive package together really
to get him and kauai
but they were all in on it then so i
guess they felt like look we're all in
there's there's no reason to mess around
with this contract extension and
have a situation that was shaky last
year in terms of
happiness and comfort and all those kind
of things i guess they felt like they
had to make him as comfortable as
possible
in fairness to james harden uh luka
doncic didn't show up in shape either
looked like he had a gut
so i you know when people say you pick
on james harden um
that's it it's a valid criticism that i
did pick on him and i didn't pick on
luka doncic luke luka duncan
listen those dudes are also
naturally thick dudes i mean let's be
honest neither one of them is ever going
to post shirtless in g2 heart is going
to
wear some fancy clothing being on the
cover but
i mean those they're they're big thick
body dudes and i'm just telling you this
james harden's weight ranks about 196
on the list of the rockets concerns
right now
[Laughter]
good stuff tim and uh you're doing a
great job i enjoy reading your stuff and
we appreciate your time
hope to have you on soon thank you
appreciate it dan that's tim mcmahon he
uh
is covering the nba for the mothership
we